so hi everybody welcome back to this
last session of today so this is last
talk of today we have Anant here with us
you will give actually a the first part
of a three talk series that the other
two talks will follow tomorrow and you
know tell us a bit about their recent
result MIP star equals to re and just
just to reiterate for anybody who may be
joining for the first time this session
if you want to ask a question during the
talk you can if you're at Annie you can
type it in the Q&A and I will tell Anant
what your question is or if you prefer
to talk to you using your microphone you
can also raise your hand and then we can
give you the opportunity to speak so
well floor is yours okay thanks for the
introduction and also thanks to the
organizers for pursuing this workshop
and also thanks to Andrea for the
previous talks I think this really late
a lot of the groundwork for what I'm
going to talk about here so hopefully I
won't be repeating too much okay so this
is the first talk in a series of three
talks on this work showing MIP star is
equal to re with you know like my
co-authors and so the first talk is
going to focus on a part of this called
the quantum low degree test so let me
start with just a little bit of
background on sort of the the problem
and good so you know in the previous
talk andre already sort of introduced
this model but let me just review it for
people so you know in the studying we're
talking about what are called non-local
games and the quantum information
literature and and the associated
quantum complexity classes so a
non-local game is a set up where you
have a classical verifier that gets to
communicate to two parties which are
called provers so these are the parties
Ellis involved in this diagram here and
during the game sort of that Alice and
Bob are spatially separated so they
cannot communicate the verifier will
come up with two random questions
according to some distribution and send
a question
to Alice and a question to Bob and then
Alice and Bob will have to each compute
an answer to their question and and
respond and give it back to the verifier
then the verify will decide whether they
have won or lost based on some predicate
so you know this is the basic set up you
have a non non-local game and sort of
the the thing you might study here is
sort of what are strategies that the the
two players Alice and Bob might use to
maximize their probability of succeeding
in the game so the quantity we call the
game value is just the supreme
improbability over all the strategies
they could use so you know they could be
classical in which case their strategy
consists of a shared random bits or some
other you know shared classical
information that they agree on in
advance or there could be quantum in
which he is allowed to share a quantum
state you know with some entanglement
and they can perform measurements on
that state when they're playing the game
so there's this classical value which is
the you know the maximum success
probability when they're playing
classically and there's a quantum value
which is the the maximum success
probability when they're playing with
shared entanglement so that's the basic
set up for these non-local games and the
intuition that you want to have for all
these things is that the you know you
should think of the players as provers
that are trying to certify something to
the verifier so you know in ondrea's
talk and in this talk we'll see that you
know often what they want to certify is
some physical property of the states
that they shared they want to certify
that they share a particular quantum
state and that they're applying certain
measurements to it but in the complexity
setting what this turns into is that you
know you can think of them as trying to
certify to the verifier that that the
answer to a certain decision problem is
yes so this is the setting that you have
an interactive proofs and so you can
define complexity classes associated
with these games called MIP
an MIP star for multi prover interactive
proofs and the star indicates the
version with entanglement so you know
these are the classes where you have
either you know quantum players or
classical players but they're trying to
convince a verifier that you're forgiven
decision problem the answer to that is
yes so
problem is you know it has a protocol
and say MIP star if you know for every
yes instant you know if there's some
game that the verifier can can play with
these provers to set for every yes
instance there's some way for the to
prove are using their entanglement maybe
to convince the verifier to accept to
know to win with high probability and
for every no instance you know there's
no way for the provers to win in the
game with high probability so that's the
basic set up and then the sequence of
talks are going to basically tell you
about you know work that characterize
the complexity of this class so just to
give you a little overview you know
here's a little diagram of complexity
classes so you know here on the Left we
have a you know a bunch of things that
are all sort of like different kinds of
problems that are that are computable
that may be in in varying amounts of
time or space so and in particular you
have the classical class that came out
of considering classical provers here so
a an old result in complexity theory is
that MIP is equal to n X on the other
hand in this diagram I have on the other
side I have this class are E which is
recursively enumerable problems and
that's the classroom which the halting
problem is the complete problem so this
is you know this this class contains
uncomputable problems and so the main
thing we're going to show you is that
you know MIP star which is that the
quantum counterpart of this MIT class is
is actually equal to the halting problem
which is you know a big contrast from
from what you get classically so that's
the overall plan for these talks in this
talk I'm going to focus on a certain
technical ingredient it goes into our
proof and to explain sort of why it's
necessary let me tell you a little bit
about just some challenges that arise
when you say naively want to understand
the complexity of my P star so if you
wanted time to understand this
complexity class well there's two
directions you might try to think about
One Direction is to try to prove an
upper bound on the class you know what's
the best upper bound you can place on on
this class within tank
perverse so as we saw in in Andrea's
talk and as I'm sure many of you have
seen you know for these non-local games
it's often possible that using a quantum
state the the quantum provers can can
can do things that classical provers
could not do right so one difficulty
with that is that in general there's no
really good theory for you know if I
give you a description of a non-local
game to figure out how many qubits or
what dimension a quantum state might be
needed for the provers to obtain an
advantage over classical strategies so
we saw you know in the previous talk CH
SH and Magic Square and and these are
games that that use one or two EPR pairs
and contain an advantage but you know
there's also games like this I 3 3 2 2
inequality that are you know constant
size games that look kind of similar to
say CH SH but we don't really know how
these behave and so it's conjectured
that actually you you know the bigger
the entangled state you have the better
you can do with this game so so adding
dimension just no strictly increases
your winning probability so that's a you
know a very simple game where we don't
have a good understanding of how how
much entanglement might be necessary so
in general this is you know this this
means that computing a complexity theory
upper bound in this class is difficult
so what does that translate to in
complexity terms well the best upper
bound you can get is just that for the
class of my piece star is you could
write down and you know for any decision
problem that's solvable and MIP star
there's the following algorithm which
also solves it so the algorithm what it
does is it just enumerate so for all
possible things that these two provers
could have done so you know all possible
classical strategies all strategies that
use one qubit all strategies that use
two qubits and so on as you increase the
dimension of the state and you wait for
this enumeration to find a good enough
strategy for that for the to prove errs
and so since there's no you know a
priori bound on on how many qubits or
what dimension of state the provers
might need we don't really know
when this enumeration my terminate and
that's why you get this upper bound of
re here so this is just like you know
for the halting problem suddenly there's
an enumeration which is just to run you
know a Turing machine until to run the
Turing machine until it halts and again
you don't know how long that's gonna
take that's that's what results in
preventing re so now this is what
happens when you try to upper bound at
my piece star and actually you know
since we ultimately show that MIP star
is equal to re you know this upper bound
is is is really tight and I won't be
able to give you any you know
improvement on this so in general you
know it will be the case that you need
you know enormous amounts of qubits like
unbounded amounts of qubits to to to you
know do well in these non-local games so
one point that I do want to make here
though is that why is this issue of the
number of qubits so important well if
you instead of considering you know MIP
star where the to prove are allowed to
use whatever entangled state they want
if you restrict the provers to use a
state of a certain upper bounded
dimension so you say you know the
approvers have to use a quantum state of
dimension at most D then you can show
that you automatically get a bound on
this complexity class that's that's
something like end time of polynomial
and D so end time is non-deterministic
time so where does that come from well
that's just from this sort of
enumeration but it's using the fact that
since you have you know this restriction
that the provers are using a quantum
state of dimension at most D then you
can you know write down a classical
description of what they do in in you
know Pauly D bits and so then you can
use this non determinism to just guess a
description of a good strategy and that
can be done in n time of poly D so no
really there's a the whole you know way
you can get up to re you know to get
beyond these these these balances is you
need to somehow deal with with provers
that use states that have no that you
can't put a
a nice bound on the dimension of so to
expand on that inside a little bit more
so I said that you know ultimately I'm
not gonna be able to improve this upper
bound that the ground is tight so that
means I have to show a lower bound that
matches it so I need to show that MIP
star is you know lower bounded
ultimately by re so how would you do
that well there's actually you know some
challenges that are involved even there
um in fact even for much more for modest
goals so you might know as a first step
want to show that MIP star is lower
bounded by its classical counterpart
that you know this this proof system
that when you have quantum Coover is
this least as powerful as double one
with classical provers and that's not a
priori you know obvious because if you
think about it allowing the provers to
share entanglement we saw these examples
at games where they can succeed with a
higher probability than they can
classically in the complexity setting
that means that it might be easier for
these provers to falsely convince a
verifier that the answer to some
computational problem is yes right now
maybe the answer is really no but they
can use the entanglement to to to cheat
the the verifier and and and convince it
to say yes so how many exams so some
examples were actually found with you
know protocols that are sound against
classical approvers but don't work once
you allow the provers to share
entanglement and you know was sort of a
technically demanding thing to show even
this lower bound that MIP star contains
a my piece you have to take a specific
classical protocol and and analyze the
steps and show that they are you know
that to prove irska not cheat using
entanglement so if you want to improve
this lower bound and you want to you
know do better so you want to show that
MIP star contains you know a larger
class of languages then ultimately what
do you need to do you need to somehow
design a protocol that uses entanglement
you know where the to prove are using
entanglement in some way because you
want to go beyond this classical
but you want to make sure that they
don't use that entanglement to cheat the
verifier so you have to somehow put
constraints on what the provers can do
with the entanglement and more
quantitatively we can say the following
that no if you remember from the
previous slide about the upper bound I
said that if the provers are restricted
to having a d-dimensional state then we
had this upper bound that's like end
time with poly and D and there was a
question about this statement actually
is this the best upper bound that we can
get for optimizing over the D
dimensional states um
I'm not entirely sure I think roughly it
should be tight like I think we should
roughly be able to show lower bound that
that matches if I don't know exactly you
know whether they're like the
polynomials match and so on okay thanks
ok so I guess the yeah so the point I
was trying to make is that so from the
previous slide we saw this this argument
that if you have this if you have a D
dimensional state then you have an upper
bound so if I want to get a lower bound
an MIP star that's as strong as possible
I need to design a protocol that uses
you know a state with as high a
dimension as possible and in particular
if I want to separate a my P star from
from the classical counterpart MIP you
know just at least I need to do to get
up to here I need to at least you and
separate it from MIP I need to start by
designing a protocol where the provers
need to use a super polynomial number of
qubits because they need to have a
dimension that's bigger than an
exponential so this is sort of the first
step along the road to ultimately
showing that MIP star is equal to re and
that's the stuff I'm going to talk about
in my talk so in this talk I'll tell you
about a protocol that lets a verifier
test that to prove errs share two to the
end copies of the EPR state so this
protocol will be a self-test in the
sense that that Andreea defined in the
previous talk
and this will also you know go a long
way ultimately this will be the fact
that it's a self-test will be useful for
you know the complexity theoretic
consequences so in in the talks tomorrow
bye-bye John and drink feng they'll tell
you how to use you know this protocol
that that self tests these EPR pairs as
well as you know a bunch of other
ingredients to actually design an MIP
star protocol for for the halting
problem and ultimately show that MIP
star is equal to re
so and maybe one point I do want to make
about that now before I dive into the
the details is that why is this notion
of self testing important here well it's
it's relate to this intuition that I
gave you earlier that when you want to
design a better lower bound for MIP star
you need a protocol that that you know
forces the provers to use entanglement
but in some specific way that you you
want to prevent them from cheating the
verifier by using that entanglement and
so the fact that the protocol and when
design here is a self-test is what lets
you do this it's what lets you prevent
the the provers from from cheating the
verifier
okay so so with that said I'm now going
to switch over to telling you about how
we're going to construct this protocol
to test to the NDP our pairs okay so you
know we already saw some definitions of
this but I'm going to review just to you
know in case you weren't in the previous
talk so um what is the know this notion
of testing EPR pairs that I want to use
well it's this this very strong notion
of self testing and how I'm going to
define it is the following so I'll say
that a game is a self test if it has the
following properties so first of all the
optimal strategy that two players can
use in the game should be unique up to
sort of the the freedom that that you
always have so that means unique up to
local isometry 's so that means that you
know Alice and Bob when they play this
game they have to share a quantum state
and so that state has to be you know the
state that that's optimal has to be
unique up to like local changes of basis
you know Alice coughs rotate her part of
the state if she does the same rotation
on her measurements and likewise Bob can
do some some local rotation as well and
you know you could never you can never
rule out such as local rotation so you
have to always leave this freedom in but
up to this inevitable freedom of local
isometry you want to say that this this
you know state and the measurements that
Alice Bob apply are unique and moreover
you want to say that this optimal
strategy is also robust in the following
sense so any um any strategy for this
game that exceed that achieves a success
probability that's close to the optimum
should itself be close to the optimal
strategy so what this means is for
instance you know if I'm playing this
game this game as a soft test and I
observed that Alice and Bob succeed with
the probability that's very close to the
the maximum probability then that should
imply that their quantum state is a you
know very close in some appropriate
distance metric so basically
you know up to local isometry some
version of this of the two norm
it should be close to this unique
optimal state so that's what you want to
say for the state and moreover we want
to say similar things for the
measurements that Alice and Bob apply as
well so we want to you know say in
addition that say you know when Alice
gets a question X from the verifier
she's going to apply a certain
measurement operator which I have
denoted a X a here and that measurement
operator as well should be close in in
the you know this to norm up to isometry
to the measurement operator that forms
part of this unique ideal strategy so so
this is the notion of self testing that
I that I want to that I want to use and
ultimately our goal in this talk will be
to design a self test in the sense where
the state sy opt here is 2 to the N
copies of the P R pair state
okay so right so how would we go about
designing such a self-test well another
question just popped up and I'm sorry
sure
Ian asks are there games with unique
ideal strategy which are enjoy bust in
the sense that you just described uh um
that's a good question actually
I think um I'm not aware of one on top
of my head so the thing is that the
robustness can depend on the dimension
of the state so you can have families of
games where you know this this point
zero one here would not be point zero
one would say point zero one times some
factor in the dimension
you know polynomial in the dimension
even so for instance like these parallel
repeated CH SH games that Andre I
mentioned are an instance of that so you
know that's that's robust that's sort of
not robust enough quantitatively for for
our purposes I would call that not
robust if you want to say you know is
there like you know is it a game where
you can play snowbound at all over here
then I'm not aware of one at the moment
okay thank you
[Music]
okay so right so I'm going to tell you
basically how to design you know a self
test for this you know two to the end
copies of the EPR state and the way
we're going to do that is in a couple of
stages so we're gonna start with a self
test for just two copies of the EPR
state and then we're going to sort of
generalize the ideas I'll show you sort
of why that self test works why this
will you know cover some ground that
Andre I mentioned but it may be a little
bit of a different language and then
I'll show you how to generalize those
ideas to testing more EPR pairs okay so
this self test for two EPR pairs this is
just the the Magic Square game which
you'll seen so just as a brief refresher
of how it works you know in the Magic
Square game the Magic Square is this 3x3
square here whose entries are supposed
to be I guess in the notation I'm using
plus or minus one valued things and so
the way it'll turn into a two-player
game is that Alice will get since I
think I slightly different formulation
maybe then when then then what was used
in the previous talk is Alice will get
um asked for either a row or a column of
this 3x3 square
Bob will be you know asked for for a
sell in the square and they have to
respond with an assignment to you know
Alice has respond for the three
variables in her row or column Bob will
have to respond with an assignment to
the one variable in his cell and so for
instance you know Alice I could asked
for four for this row or or that column
and then Bob will be asked for cell that
lies on Alice's row or column and so you
know they had to respond with assignment
disease variables and then they win if
the following conditions hold so first
you have these parity conditions that
the rows have to multiply to one the
columns are to multiply two minus one
and Alice and Bob have to agree on the
common cell so you know you can check
that there's no classical strategy that
wins the probability one in this in this
game essentially because there's no
consistent assignment to all the entries
in the square that satisfy these parity
conditions and however there is a
perfect quantum strategy which has value
one and that perfect quantum strategy is
the one that we're going to try to show
is is unique and robust in these senses
so what's the intuition behind this this
disproof will have to first tell you
what a quantum strategy looks like so in
general you know a quantum strategy is
gonna look like like something so um
it's gonna consist of you know there's
going to be a state that Alice and Bob
have to share and actually you know to
satisfy this condition that Alice and
Bob should always agree on the cell they
share in common we're gonna have them
use the EPR state and the EPR state has
this nice property that if you perform
the same measurement on both halves of
it you get the same outcome essentially
so you know this will this will give you
this sort of consistency condition for
free that's why the EPR state shows up
and then to specify the rest of the
strategy you have to specify some
measurement operators for Alice and Bob
you know when they're asked for these
rows or columns or individual cells and
so the way the specification will be
given is just we'll specify a binary
observable for every cell that satisfy
the conditions that um well first of all
every every row or column should should
pairwise commute just so that Alice can
can say measure everything in the same
row or everything in the same column
simultaneously and secondly you know the
product of everything in a given row or
given in a given row should be equal to
the identity operator that enforces this
condition that you get you know this
parity condition that the product of the
outcomes on a row should be equal to one
and the product of the observables in a
column should be minus the identity
operator so that enforces this condition
that the the product of the outcomes
should be equal to minus one
and then finally you have this thing
that you know each row or column will
pairwise commute and that's just that
Alice is able to simultaneously measure
all the things in a given row work you
can call up so this is we have one more
question about this from Dominique it's
a rather long one I'll read it out he
says he has a problem with the idea of
the self testing so the guarantees that
there is an EPR pair so say that a game
guarantees that there's an EPR pair so
that means that this state is an EPR
pair up to local isometry or local
unitary he says but what if there is
another strategy that uses two EPR pairs
and just ignores one of them that's not
equal to one EP are pair up to unitary
and you ask what did I get wrong here
very good so this is a point that I kind
of brushed under the rug so this is why
in part where we say isometry and and
not unitary so actually what I should
have written there is you know say EPR
or so you know the optimal state tensor
some junk state so the isometry has you
know an output register and then a
second register that can have any other
state that you want and the important
thing about this junk state is actually
you'll see it two slides from now but
I'll say a bit more about it then but so
the you know if you had like a second EP
I repaired that the provers just
happened not to use you could you could
basically toss it into the junk state
and the ideal strategy should be such
that you know or that it doesn't act on
on the junk state so I yeah so this is
this like second EP Arbor that he's
mentioning it would just be the junk
part that's right yeah thank you
sure right okay
um okay so on the previous slide I sort
of said what this ideal quantum strategy
will look like and then you know I
specified in terms of some constraints
on these observables and so you can
actually work out a set of observables
that works and these observables are
just tensor products of two of the Pauli
matrices acting on on two qubits so the
state that Alice and Bob will share is
two copies of the EPR state so you know
Alice has two qubits and Bob has two
qubits and then each of these cells an
observable that Alice or Bob will apply
you know to their set of two qubits so
so so each cell is a two qubit
observable and those observables all
have the form of being tensor products
of poly matrices so let's say this is no
an identity tensor probably Sigma X
which I've just denoted by X here like
this cell this cell is really like a Y
tensor Y and and and so that for
simplicity I've written in this x times
Z tensor Z times X so you can so you can
check that you know these operators
satisfy all the conditions that I said
on the on the previous slide and give
you a valid strategy so so that's the
unique ideal strategy and then what's
the guarantee that you get as for this
game being a self test well okay this
will maybe answer a Dominic's question a
little bit so what you get is is
ultimately that um if any strategy you
know that that succeeds in this game is
probability greater than 1 minus epsilon
then what's true of it is that there's
some local isometry z-- you acting on
Alice's space and V acting on Bob's face
such that you know they take the state
that Alice and Bob share and they map it
to something that's close to two copies
of the EPR states that's like the ideal
state tensor some junk state so that's
what they do to the state and then for
the measurements they also map all of
the measurements you know all of these
nine observables here to the
corresponding entries in the ideal
strategy so for instance observable
number two if you remember from the
chart before it was supposed to be Polly
X tensor
probably I and so the statement that we
have is that under the action of these
local isometry x' this observable number
two gets mapped to something that looks
like Polly X tends to Polly I acting on
the EPR estate and then sort of identity
acting on the junk state
so that's the statement that this game
is a self-test so how does one prove
such a statement well here's a little
intuition so if you look at this this
ideal strategy I said that you know
there are these commutation conditions
that you know within a given row or a
given column things have to commute but
one thing you can realize is that it's
somehow essential that outside of a row
or a column you know if two things fly
on different rows or different columns
that that they not commute because so if
everything commuted then you could say
I'm not finis Li measure all the
observables in this square and then
you'd get a classical assignment to the
square which is something that we know
does not exist so somehow this non
commutation idea has to be important
here and so the way that that idea is
gonna be used is it we're gonna try to
actually you know just from the
condition that this set of observables
satisfies the Magic Square wouldn't
extract some algebraic properties that
will hopefully pin down the unique
strategy so to formalize this this is
sort of the the idea that that of self
testing through representation theory so
the way it's gonna work here is that
will actually do the following so you
know as you you probably know that the
Pauli matrices generated a group called
the poly group with with the following
relations so so the x and z operators
are the the poly x and z matrices and
they're the generators of this group and
they have the relations that you know
each of them squares to identity and
moreover that X times Z is equal to
minus Z times X so X and Z anti commute
this is like an algebraic structure that
you have here moreover there's a unique
unitary representation that's that's
non-trivial in the sense that in this
representation minus the identity is
distinct from the identity so this is
like the sign operator that this is J
that that Andrei I mentioned is you non
trivial so it means that this J equals
identity but so this unique
representation is essentially the the
the standard one that you've
you've probably seen you know it's just
the poly matrices acting on a qubit that
has dimension 2 and moreover the unique
state that's stabilized by X tenser X
and Z tenser Z you know in this
representation so you need to say that's
a plus 1 eigen value those two things is
the EPR state so putting these facts
together you know if you wanted to show
a self test for the EPR state one way
you could do it is by you know somehow
deducing from success in in the game but
there's exists an e-rep of the polygroup
in the the hilbert space of the two
perverse and moreover that the state
that the poopers use is stabilized by
the representations of X sensor X and Z
tensor Z in that era once you have that
since you know that this Arup is unique
you you can basically extract the state
out so that's basically we're going to
do for the magic square actually you
know we have to do something little bit
more complicated because it's it's it's
two EPR pairs and not one so you have to
use the polygroup on two cute qubits and
that has a set of relations it's
essentially you know you just like
generalize the one qubit relations in
natural way this is what you get so I
won't really say too much about it and
you know this is that the only
non-trivial Europe has dimension four so
this is how you can you can test for two
copies of the EPR state so just as a
schematic diagram of how this proof
approach works it basically goes as
follows so the argument is I'm gonna
start with some strategy for the Magic
Square game that succeeds the
probability 1 minus epsilon so from that
I'll construct you know this strategy
has some state and some observables is
these a a 1 up to a 9 so the first step
in the analysis is going to be the
following so I'm going to construct some
operators in in the provers Hilbert
space that all right with Tilda's so a
construct toted versions of all these
nine observables here such that they're
close to what the provers actually apply
they're close to these on
tilted things from the strategy and
moreover the tilted operators exactly
satisfy the the group relations at the
polygroup so know for instance if you
remember back from the strategy earlier
you know a2 and a4 were supposed to be
basically the poly X and the poly z
acting on the first qubit so they were
supposed to be no anti commuting so in
the first step of this analysis I'm
gonna try to construct this an operator
a tilde - and an operator a tilde for
that are close to these a 2 and a 4 but
exactly satisfy the anti commutation
relation so this step the way you can
think about it is that you're showing
that the structure of the Magic Square
game itself you know some of this this
the fact that you have these conditions
that rows should should multiply to 1
and columns multiply to minus 1 but that
structure is is testing the relations of
the polygroup you know these kinds of
relations here ok so then in the second
step we apply this fact from the
previous slide that there was like you
know unique unique representation so
once you have constructed these
operators on the provers space that
satisfy the polygroup relations there's
an isometry that map's them to the
elements of the polygroup you know - 2 x
tensor i or z tensor i or whatever the
case may be and then finally to obtain
the so you can think about this as like
you know we're trying to sew these like
you know sort of what we showed here is
that these A's are like a approximate
representation of the group and we're
rounding it to an exact representation
on the group and then mapping that to
the the canonical one which is just the
poly matrices and then I saw I realized
that this arrow really should be
pointing at this at this year so this is
really what's going doing the rounding
but anyway um you can you can ignore
this if you would like so so once you've
reached this stage here so what have we
done with construction isometry that
map's the provers operators to to these
poly matrices and then finally how you
can use this isometry
um plus the condition that you know you
you win in the game to deduce that the
states I was stabilized by this you know
X tensor X or Z tensor Z and that tells
you that psy was close to being two
copies of the EPR state so this is a
sort of at a high level how how the
analysis of the Magic Square game is a
self test works so I mean this is a good
point to ask for any questions
okay so if not I'll continue so what
have I done so far so I basically showed
you how this magic square as a self-test
for two EPR pairs works but in this
framework of representation theory so
ultimately we're going to try to do is
so I had some slides sort of showing you
how you know the structure of the game
how to do this first step so how the
structure of the game you know implies
the anti commutation relations but maybe
I'll skip over these so this is this
sort of essentially if you know if you
work through the algebra like what these
winning conditions mean they can going
to do santa commutation on them it's a
little bit painful but so now I'm going
to tell you how to generalize this idea
to many qubits so I'll do this in two
steps the first generalization will be
something called the Polly braiding test
which will be able to test many qubits
it'll test basically n qubits but sort
of ultimately we want to go up to two to
the N so then in the second stuff I'll
tell you how to to make the this test
even more efficient and how you can get
to an exponential number of EPR pairs so
how do I generalize this so ok so first
let me tell you what the result is for
this Polly braiding test so the probably
draining test is a a game just like the
Magic Square game but with the following
properties so in the Magic Square you
know everything was constant size here
the questions that the verifier will
send to the provers are now on the order
of n bits long the the provers will
still respond with answers that are on
the order of 1 bit long so there's that
constant number of bits and this game
has quantum value 1 so there's no
quantum strategy that succeeds with
probability 1 and it's a robust self
test for for n copies of the EPR state
so the prover succeeded probability 1
minus epsilon and there's some function
of epsilon close to having this state so
how will it work well it's going to use
the representation theory of a bigger
group so it'll be the same approach but
using a bigger group and that group will
just be the poly matrices on n qubits so
a few questions probably took people a
bit of time to to type them up so I have
two questions for you the first one is
do you have a good reference for the
magic square self-test because it
written down somewhere uh yes so I guess
the original reference is this paper by
Wu at all from 2015
I think uncle McCaig and scrawny I hope
I'm not forgetting any authors and I
think you can also find like I think say
the paper of aundrea or like the papers
by Andre Angelics and also by myself and
Matt Kudrin will we analyze the parallel
repeated case you know we go through
some of the same calculations so like I
think there might have been a typo and
one of the original papers that like
there's a signer that that we tried to
correct in the in the paper with Matt
Kudrin so that's that's a reference that
you could also look at okay
great thank you and another question is
someone asks the stabilisers of the EPR
pair are at Z times Z and X times X but
a2 and a4 are supposed to be close to x
times y and z times y and i don't know
what that's the question I think they're
confused about this oh sure
okay so I guess this this issue of like
what the tensor product symbol means so
so when we talk about the the stabilizer
condition okay so maybe I'll say like
you know in this in this picture here if
like what a 2 and a 4 are this tensor
product is across the two qubits got
Alice holes right so Alice will hold two
qubits which are half of the two EPR
pairs and and says you know apply X the
first qubit and I to the second for the
stabilizer relation that tensor product
was across Alice and Bob so actually I
think I wrote what it is for for two EPR
pairs sorry just here so you know for
two EPR pairs if you write out the full
thing it's you know you should be
stabilized by you know X I on Alice's
side tensor xin bob side and likewise IX
and
sucide tensor IX on Bob side so you
basically check all these stabilizer
relations in the game and I hope that
that answered the question I think so
another way still so just ask you you
thank you okay so click back to where we
were okay so it's going to tell you
about this um you know n-cubed polygroup
so the N cubed poly group is really the
the natural generalization of the two
cubed poly group or the the one cubit
poly group that we already saw
so it's essentially the group that you
get out of tensor products of these poly
matrices and I'm going to use this this
sort of nice notation for them to index
these tensor products across n qubits
I'm going to just use a string or a
vector and f2 to the end so it's a
binary vector of length N and it'll just
tell me you know which indices to put
say in X or which n disease to put an
identity so this X of a means put an X
and every qubit where a is 1 and an
identity wherever a is 0 so in this
notation you can write out the relations
you get when you multiply these X's and
Z's and they have a very nice form so
remember for the polygroup we had this
relation you know x squared is equal to
identity you know here in general you
can multiply two different X's that act
on different sets of qubits and what you
find is that the indicator vectors that
tell you what sets they act on just add
mod to so that's that's essentially you
know just a generalization this x
squared equals identity rule and
likewise for a Z so I take 2z Poly's and
I multiply them then the the index
vectors will add mod 2 and then finally
if I try to take an X and a Z and
commute them past each other
I'll pick up a phase that goes as minus
1 to the inner product of a dot B
essentially because you get a phase from
anti commuting Z and an X whenever a and
B are both 1 on a given location so so
these are the relations of the polygroup
and sort of just like
I'm going to give them names I'm going
to call these first two relations here
that the linearity relations and the
last one the the phase relation so no
just like the for the for the basic
polygroup the only non trivial Europe
had dimension two and O sort of that the
canonical thing with that the poly
matrices here the only non-trivial Arab
has dimension 2 to the N and it's also
the canonical representation where you
take tensor products of poly matrices so
what are we going to do to design this
poly Brading test well we want to do
sort of exactly the same thing that
happened with the magic square so I'm
going to figure out you know some sort
of game it's probably raining test such
that if a strategy to that game succeed
the probability 1 minus epsilon then the
operator is used in that strategy all
approximately satisfy these relations of
the polygroup and then in our analysis
will show that you know once you you
have operators that approximately
satisfy these relations they're close to
operators that exactly satisfy the group
relations this is the step that we
called rounding to an exact
representation so for the Magic Square
you know this is a calculation that you
could just do directly for the polygroup
that's just n cubed polygroup this is
also a calculation you can do and but
but but there's also a more general
framework so in fact this sort of thing
can be done for any finite group and
this is shown by Gower's and hitomi so
in general when you have an approximate
representation in a certain sense you
can round it to an exact representation
so then once you've constructed this
this exact representation of the
polygroup on the provers space that lets
you you know construction isometry to
rotate everything to the poly matrices
and then by a similar argument as a
magic square you know by this like
stabilized or type argument you can say
that that that therefore the the you
know isometry takes the state side that
the primers used and takes it to be
close to end copies in the UPR state so
this is the the the analysis that we
want to hold so ok so what are the steps
that um so this stuff is you know it's
just a mathematical
theorem but it's a fact about these
approximate representations where do we
need to use our quantum ingenuity or we
need to somehow construct a game that
certifies you know these polygroup
relations and gives you the the
stabiliser relations you need to deduce
the state but really the the tricky step
is getting these polygroup relations so
how is that going to work well it's
because this we're just going to really
look at what these two different
relations look like and design sort of a
game that can test for each one of them
separately so first I'll start with the
easier case so remember that there is
this phase relation here which you know
whenever a and B have an inner product
that's equal to one this is just
certifying that that this X of a
observable and this is he of be
observable anticommute so for this one
it turns out we actually already know a
way to test an anti commutation relation
that's exactly what the Magic Square
game did remember so one thing that we
got out of the Magic Square is for
instance that that the two four then the
a two entry in the a four entry anti
commute and so we can use the the Magic
Square to certify that any pair of
observables that the the provers use
anti commute in the following way we
just instruct the provers to play the
magic score game but using you know
those particular observables as you know
the as what they used to measure that
entry of the square so we'll sort of
measure will play the Magic Square game
and then we'll identify you know the
cell number two with this X of a
observable and and cell number four with
the Z of be observable and then by
success in the Magic Square game that
certifies that these two observables
anticommute so you know we'll specify an
A and a B for them and we'll tell them
play the Magic Square using these two
observables and and and and if they
succeed that certify is the anti
commutation relation and and what's the
what's the relation between sy and the
calligraphic x and z that's a question
in the Q&A so sy is is the
state the so sign in the calligraphic
letters are all part of the the provers
strategy that that succeeds with nearly
optional probability SOSUS I was the
sting that succeeds with probably one
minus epsilon and then these
calligraphic X and Z's were the
operators that they would they measured
on-site during the game yeah so those
are the kind of the real operators and
then the non calligraphic x and z are
the ideal things that you want that you
would have wanted them to do that's
right yeah thanks okay so the Magic
Square game can already you know certify
this kind of relation that can certify
this anti commutation now the other
class of relations was this linearity
relation and actually you know there's
already sort of a test for for this kind
of relation in the world of boolean
functions this is called the the
linearity test so it turns out you know
there's this test that if you just have
sure maybe maybe it's easier if I just
say it in the quantum case so I'll just
show you the the quantum test and I'll
explain how it works
so essentially you know there's this
test that's already known for these
kinds of linearity relations that that
can certify that you have to you know if
you have a boolean function f then then
F of a times F of B is close to F of a
plus B and so it turns out that the same
test when you analyze it with
observables will certify these sort of
operator linearity relations so how does
the test work well it's it's basically
the following so if I want to check that
Alice and Bob's calligraphic X
observables satisfy this relation for
particular a and B what I'll do is I'll
just tell Alice you know I want you to
to measure in the X basis and I'm going
to ask you to measure X of a and X of B
so Center X comma a comma B and then
I'll tell Bob X I'll tell them the sum a
plus B and I'll give him a andum you
know third vector C it's just to is like
a decoy so he doesn't know that that
that he's being you know sort of is
being tested against Alice so so you
know Alice and Bob will get these things
and what they'll they're supposed to do
is measure the corresponding
calligraphic X server balls for the two
vectors that they received soon for
Alice it would be measure X of a and X
of B for Bob would be measure X of a
plus B and X of C and then they'll
respond with the outcomes and then what
we'll check is just that the product of
Alice's two outcomes is equal to Bob's
outcome for for a plus B and so the
analysis that you can do is is that if
you if you do this test and you just do
this check on the outcomes then if you
succeed with high probability then the
observables that Alice and Bob use to
execute the test have to satisfy these
operator equations up to up to a some
approximation so this is how you test
these these linearity relations from the
group so Ashley is asking if you can
elaborate a little bit about the mapping
between these relations these anti
commutation relations and the Magic
Square game he says he's missing the
correspondence between the two as well
ah sure so let me scroll back I guess
also about even just a single EPR fair
then okay so okay so for the Magic
Square game for a single EPR pair I
guess sort of what you show in the
analysis is that just from the condition
that you succeed with probability close
to one you know that's that sort of
means that it's like let's say the
product of these three observables is
close to the identity operator and the
product of these three observables going
vertically is close to minus eight and
in the operator just from like you know
doing some algebraic manipulations on
these equations you get so get an
equation for each row an equation for
each column you can deduce that let's
say this cell here and this cell here
are close to anti commuting so that's
just some algebra you can do
and the way it's used here is that in
general if you want if you want Alice
and Bob to certify to you that the
observables they use in response to
certain questions they're anti commuting
what you can do is is you ask them you
send them the questions that you want to
certify anti commute and then you say I
want you to play the Magic Square using
those observables to construct your
strategy so you'll then say you know
Alice I want I'll give you a random row
or column from the square and Bob asked
you for a random cell in a row or a
column and I want you to measure you
know to execute the ideal strategy for
Magic Square but but using the you know
calligraphic X of a or calligraphic Z of
B that I instructed you to use and so
because you know in the ideal case the
calligraphic X's and Z's anti commute
they can indeed do this successfully and
and then they can win in the game and
and and because of this this property
that I mentioned earlier that if you
succeed with high probability you have
to anti commute I mean that that
certifies that the calligraphic x and z
used for these two cells will will be
close to anti commuting but maybe this
one follow-up ones are what I'm missing
is y1 can be how we ensure that the
players will follow the instruction to
use these particular operators very good
so that was actually the the next thing
I was about to say I'm on this side is
that you you further want so the
question is essentially how do you know
they're using the same operators when
you're testing for anti commutation as
they are using in the other test right
that's right so you essentially have to
do a consistency sort of test which is
new to say that whatever calligraphic
you know thing they use in the linearity
test was the same as in the magic square
test and so the way you do that is you
you just tell one player you tell Alice
that you're playing the linearity game
and you tell Bob that you're playing the
Magic Square game and you cross check
that the part of their answers is
supposed to agree so
you know see you asked Bob for a row in
the magic square you check that the cell
you know that was supposed to contain
the Z operator is actually consistent
with Alice's answer from the linearity
game for that Z operator
I see Thanks okay so so what have I
shown you I said there's this approach
to to self testing many EPR pairs
through representation theory what we
needed to get that approach off the
ground was a game that tested the
relations of the polygroup and and I
basically shown you how to construct
such a game so you need a part that
tests the anti commutation relations a
part the tests of linearity relations
and then this is very important
consistency test that I shouldn't have
glossed over that that um that tests
that knew your that sort of links the
two tests together but so basically the
the the poly braiding test is
essentially running you know you pick
you flip a random coin and you run one
of these these three possibilities and
if you succeed in this test that implies
that all these relations have told you
know up to some some epsilon error and
then you can you can turn the crank of
the implications that I showed you know
if you decide to go and use that to
deduce the existence of a representation
the polygroup and therefore that the
state is close to the EPR state so this
let us test n qubits using you know
questions of size order n and if you
looked at the tests closely the the way
that n came into it is is when you are
specifying these A's and B's from the
linearity test here you know these are
these are n bit strings and that's why
the questions here have length n so I
see that I'm running quite low on time
so I'm just going to very briefly
conclude with like a sketch of how you
how you make this more efficient so to
make this more efficient we want to sort
of use the same framework with
representation theory but we wanted to
get beyond this this idea of just
testing a single group relation at a
time so if you looked at the the poly
braiding test
so the the individual subtests rather
you picked a particular pair of things
that that were supposed to anticommute
and you tested that or you you picked a
particular pair of things they're
supposed to multiply or until the new
already rule and just at that now in the
polygroup they're there for one of the
end group elements and so just to
specify you know a pair of group
elements will require like you know n
bits which is so that means if you want
to test you know two to the any PR pairs
you need to specify two to the N bits to
the provers which which we don't want to
allow so we have to somehow test many of
the group relations simultaneously and
this is this is what the the quantum
low-degree test does so the way the
intuition behind it is is the following
so there's an alternate perspective you
could have for the the poly braiding
test at least for the linearity
relations which is this just that when
you're asking approver to measure this
poly X of a what you could think about
that is that they could take their n
qubits measure all the qubits to get an
outcome you you know an N bit outcome
and then compute the inner product of
that you with with the given index
vector a so that's the same you know
ultimately gives you the same outcome as
measuring this observable X of a you
could interpret this whole procedure as
saying measure all the qubits to get
this outcome U and then return the 8th
location of the Hadamard encoding of you
so the how do our code is is an error
correcting code that's that's just
defined as the evaluation of inner
products of you with all vectors so this
is you know a particular error
correcting code with some nice
properties so it's it's a locally
testable code and and and so on but it
um is there a pore rate so you know this
this string you it's encoded into all
the possible inner products with all the
possible a's and that's you know sort of
why the the poly braiding test had had
this large communication complexities
that just specify one of these a's which
takes a lot of communication so what if
there was a code that that sort of had a
better rate that that could you know
encode this you with with fewer fewer
bits so indeed there isn't such a code
it's called the low degree code and
very at a high level the way it works is
that instead of encoding all the inner
products of you with some vector a you
fit a low degree polynomial through
points you know so that's value at
certain points is equal to two locations
in you and then you evaluate that low
degree polynomial at other points so the
encoding is just the evaluation table of
this low degree polynomial and so so
basically we in in our you know quantum
low degree test what we can do is is
replace the linearity test so so the
test for these linearity relations with
a test for this low degree code and this
is somehow much more efficient and this
lets you really test for it for two to
the N EPR pairs with polynomial size
questions or if you scale it down it's
any PR pairs of long sized questions and
so one way you can think of that is that
really it's checking many of these sort
of linearity type relations at once it's
checking many of the no relations
between different X observables
simultaneously and similar you know many
relations of different Z's observable
simultaneously and it's doing it by
checking a carefully chosen subset of
these X and z observables that comes out
of this low degree error correcting code
so it's it's really the X's and Z's that
are indexed by I guess like columns and
a generator matrix for this code so I
think I'm basically out of time if I'm
people want to stick around I'm happy to
explain a little bit more how this test
works but essentially you use the the
properties of the classical low degree
code to sort of deduce you know many
relations that you would have to check
individually in the poly bracing
braiding test so okay that's basically
concludes my talk and I'll just leave up
these these two open questions so the
open questions are essentially you know
to understand sort of the representation
picture a little bit better and and also
can we really push this this approach to
the limit and and get say a test for for
any P R pairs with constant size
questions
it's great thank you Thanks so if
there's any questions well if you're a
panelist you can just unmute yourself to
ask the question if you're a participant
you can type it and Daniel asks can you
say something about what an approximate
representation is yeah so an approximate
representation is just um you know a set
of let's say unitary matrices so you
know for every element in the group this
unitary matrix such that the group
multiplication rule holds approximately
up to some norm you know under some norm
so in our setting the norm we're using
is this funny thing called the
state-dependent norm so if I can I don't
know if I can find it in my slides but
it's essentially saying you'll see for
the poly group that we have an
approximate representation of the
polygroup if you know XZ acting on the
states I is approximately equal to 2
minus ZX acting on the states I wear the
approximation is now on in the two norm
but there are notions like you could
just consider this and say that
Frobenius norm like the multiplication
rule should hold up to some Epsilon in
the Frobenius norm Thanks I also
questioned myself
in the meantime other people can maybe
type some stuff if they want so you you
very briefly mentioned this low degree
test at the end but maybe this is
getting ahead of the topic maybe it will
appear in the other times but why do we
need this if we're in a setting where
we're essentially not worried about
efficiency like in this mi P star and re
we're not worried about time complexity
or number of rounds ourself right so why
do you want to have these tests be more
efficient sure so that's a very good
question actually so this exponential
efficiency that if you test for to the
NEP are pairs that's not really
necessary but I guess what you will need
is you need some sort of like you I
think you at least need some super
polynomial efficiency like you need the
the number of EPR pairs that you test to
be super polynomial in the number of
it's that you send to the crew versus
questions and I think John will get into
a little bit more but essentially it's
because in these protocols you're kind
of using these tests to like sort of
expand randomness like you send some
randomness to the provers as questions
but they have to generate more by
measuring EPR Paris and burn up your
resources faster than you're generating
them essentially exactly so if you use
like say the poly abrading tests or like
some parallel repeated CH SH test you'd
sort of like just like be chugging along
in place like the amount of randomness
you'd send in would all be used up and
you get no more from the reverse okay
thanks now Laura asks so she says the C
SSH game also tests anti commutation so
could you have gotten the same results
by using CSS H in place of Magic Square
yes
so we could have the only annoyance is
that it's not a value one so none of
these games would be perfect
completeness and I think that the
perfect completeness definitely makes
the analysis a lot easier for for the
MIP so our protocols so that was I guess
one reason to use Magic Square okay I
also had a question so when you say that
is like the strategy is approximately
equals to this strategy that you want to
set us I guess it is some sort of
average average closeness right because
if there is like one particular operator
when just the two words just like decide
to do some arbitrary random thing that
you might never test that particular one
that's right yeah so it's it's on
average over the same distribution that
you use to sample all the questions for
the prefers okay and then this is also
that this also holds for these
approximate representations yeah yeah so
it's so it's really that but like on
average the group represent group
relations holds and if I pick a random
pair of group elements and I check the
group relation that that should hold on
average up to Epsilon okay thank you
there's another question from Chinmayi
he asks hi Anand can you talk about the
relationship between
this pv low-degree test and this poly
grading low degree test and your games
version of the Poynting PCP theorem oh
yeah so I guess um it's a little bit of
a long story I guess
the relation is ultimately that once you
have so this is an idea that goes back I
guess really to this paper Fitzsimmons
and Vinick
I also some works buy it buy it buy
Cheng Feng Jie but sort of once you have
a test for EPR pairs that can test for
poly matrices on those EPR pairs then
you can lift it to a test for code words
of a stabilizer code by you know if it's
like say a seven qubit the seven cubed
code or something then then this would
be like a test with seven provers so
it's like you know code words that are
split amongst approvers the idea is that
all of those code words look sort of
locally like like EPR states like they
they look you know if I take the cut of
like one prover versus all the others it
looks like an EPR state so you can lift
these tests to test for code words and
then you can imagine designing protocols
where you try to force the provers to
share an error corrected encoding of
some state you care about like say the
ground state to a local Hamiltonian and
then you can you can both tests that
they had the state and also force them
to execute measurements on the state and
so that's what went into this quantum
games PCP so we essentially you know
came with the protocol that that made
the you know the prover share like a an
encoding of some low energy state to a
Hamiltonian and then we're able to
efficiently measure the energy of this
shared State cool thanks one final
question maybe from Daniel he asks any
intuition on how to around and how to
round to an exact representation
yeah I guess maybe the intuition the
best intuition that I have comes from
thinking about the the classical
linearity case actually so the case
where you just have a boolean function
and you want to say that if it passes
this this test that I showed that it's
close to a linear function so that
analysis can you can think of that just
doing this rounding for representations
of the abelian group Z 2 to the N and
the way the proof works is by free
analysis over the group so you take this
boolean function and you say that if it
passes the test with high probability
then its Fourier decomposition it has
like one fourier coefficient at least
one for your coefficient that's very
large and then that large Fourier
coefficient is itself like an exact
representation as you know a large like
that for your coefficient gives you a
linear function so in general the
analysis sort of generalizes this where
you take the Fourier transform over the
group and so the Fourier transform like
you get you find that particular
representation in the very decomposition
that has a high weight and that's that's
how you do the rounding see thanks all
right well I think this ends the session
then so thank you or not for the great
talk it was very clear I know I learned
a lot so that's good one announcement
for tomorrow and Thursday for everybody
is still listening we'll end it a
difference or we'll start at a different
time than yesterday and today so it's
the talks are going to start at 11:30
Pacific time this is to accommodate for
people in different time zones so if
you're in Europe you have to stay up
late or walk it watch it the next
morning
I guess if an aunt wants to stay around
you can stick around to ask him some
questions if you want and otherwise see
you tomorrow thanks everyone
Thanks